[Musik]
einen guten abend 22 15 haben wir es an
diesem donnerstagabend sie sind wir sind
auch hier sind unsere gäste und das ist
unser thema um krieg und frieden geht es
leider nicht nur bei tolstoi sondern
heute auch bei uns russland kann die
ukraine jederzeit überfallen sagen die
amerikaner alles hysterie er sagt man in
moskau und was sagt berlin frieden
schaffen mit waffen will man nicht aber
reden mit putin nur worüber genau und
wer fragt eigentlich die ukraine die
lage ist ernst und kompliziert wir
müssen reden mit diesen gästen
caterina micenko die ukrainische autorin
sagt ohne waffenlieferungen kann sich
die ukraine nicht verteidigen
norbert räth kennen der
cdu-außenpolitiker ist überzeugt putin
will die landkarte europas verändern
omid nouripour der neue grünen chef sagt
wir sind in diesem konflikt an der seite
der ukraine
ulrike franke die sicherheitsexperten
stellt fest deutschlands bündnispartner
sind enttäuscht
der spd-politiker martin schulz sagt die
eu ist zerstritten das ermutigt putin
und wladislaw below
der politologe aus moskau sagt russland
will nicht nach kiew es wird von der
nato bedroht sie sind zu gast bei
maybrit illner und die begrüßt die gäste
ausgesprochen herzlich schön dass sie
alle mit dabei sind die einen warnen vor
krieg die anderen vor hysterie
entspannt ist die lage jedenfalls nicht
ist das naiv oder schlicht inkompetent
russische truppen marschieren auf
deutschland marschiert ins abseits
nachdrücklich und mit geballter faust
werden 5000 helme an die ukraine liefern
auch als ganz deutliches signal wir
stehen an eurer seite
erst lazarette
jetzt helme ein kommunikativer super gau
die situation ist so zugespitzt zwischen
dem aggressiven russland gegenüber
eine ukraine die keinen krieg will dass
es gerechtfertigt ist waffen an die
ukraine zu liefern
während die usa jetzt 2000 soldaten nach
deutschland und polen entsenden
der innen spanier und briten waffen
flugzeuge und schiffe in die region
schicken bleibt der deutsche kanzler im
ungefähren und klammert sich an den
konjunktiv dass wir klar sagen was
passieren würde das eine militärische
aggression schwerwiegende konsequenzen
nach sich zöge das ist ein sehr hohen
preis haben würde
alles andere als abschreckend die
deutsche botschaft an den kreml
da sind viele konjunktive unterwegs er
war kanzlerkandidat ist vorsitzender der
spd gewesen lange präsident des europa
parlament ist jetzt bei der friedrich
ebert stiftung herr schulz man kann
diese waffenlieferungen in die ukraine
natürlich ablehnen aber wer ist
eigentlich auf die idee mit diesem 5000
händen gekommen mannschaft die ukraine
hat darum gebeten dass diese regel
geliefert werden und das ist also
richtig und was unabhängig davon ist
niemand auf die idee gekommen dass es
ein bisschen peinlich sein könnten
glaube ich nicht wir haben im
koalitionsvertrag klar festgelegt es
übrigens auch die tradition der
deutschen außenpolitik in krisengebiete
keine waffen zu liefern und sehe ich
keine veranlassung wo mit einer
waffenlieferung an die ukraine die
zugegebenermaßen extrem
angespannte lage
entspannt werden könnte ich glaube das
ist nicht die zeit über elbe oder über
waffenlieferungen zu diskutieren sondern
welche möglichkeiten gibt es sie haben
sich die angespannte situation zu lösen
das ist eine lage in der wir nicht über
waffen die von reden sollten sondern
über die wege zur diplomatischen
beruhigung das ist übrigens ganz
interessant weil sie an klitschko gerade
eingesendet haben eingeblendet haben das
ist auch die haltung des ukrainischen
präsidenten der darum bittet dass wir
diese verbale
spirale die gerade abläuft es ist
manchmal die haltung von herrn sie
lenski abhängig davon ob er zu seiner
eigenen bevölkerung spricht die möchte
er beruhigen oder aber ob er zu seinen
ausländischen partnern spricht und
nochmal die deutschland die deutsche
regierung hat wenigstens die
bündnispartner damit verwirrt mit 5000
händen um die ecke zu kommen wenn sie
sagen das ist nicht der fall würde mich
das wundern wenn sie nicht wahrnehmen
dass man wenigstens diplomatisch darauf
auch reagiert hat ganz sicher ist das so
dass die verkürzung der ganzen debatte
um 5.000 helm witzig wirkt er eher sind
aber in anderen situation finde ich
hoffe unsere pizza dich leisten können
und die berühren bedauere dass ich sie
dann korrigieren muss er sie lynskey
wendet sich auch an das ausland hat den
abzug des amerikanischen
botschaftspersonals als panikreaktion
bezeichnet also glaube schon dass wir
ein bisschen mehr auf die ukrainische
regierung hören sollten und das ganze
etwas runter nehmen diplomatische
lösungen sucht diplomatische lösungen
hören wir auch die anderen gäste omid
nouripour ist bei uns frisch gewählte
präsident wollte ich schon sein so weit
sind die große bild vorsitzender von den
grünen die fdp und die grünen tun sich
herr nouripour das sage ich mal salopp
nicht so schwer mit auch
waffenlieferungen
von defensivwaffen wird gesprochen auch
sie sprechen von nachtsichtgeräten sie
sprechen davon dass man auch einsätze
sie begleiten könnte und müsste um die
ukraine dazu unterstützen sagen sie das
immer noch und glauben sie dass das auch
nötig ist um politisch den druck zu
machen den marieluise beck hier auch
benennt es gibt die vereinbarung der
alten regierung keine legalen waffen zu
liefern und das gilt weiterhin auch in
dieser regierung und alles was darunter
ist ist natürlich diskutierbar aber ich
sehe völlig richtig was herr schulz
gesagt hat die ukrainische seite muss
auch sagen präzise sagen was sie möchte
und das ist nicht zwingend der fall
gewesen aber es ist auch richtig jetzt
ist die stunde der diplomatie und wir
müssen darauf achten dass wir diese
balance zwischen dialogen härte nicht
aufgeben gar nicht sein dass wir jetzt
mit mit einer lauten diskussion über
waffenlieferungen auch spielräume der
diplomatie werde jetzt auch einengen das
ist sicher nicht hilfreich aber
rechtlich israel 5000 nehme oder nicht
wir kennen die offiziellen anforderungen
denen ist weit wie möglich auch
tatsächlich derzeit stattgegeben worden
und es ist auch gelaufen andere anfragen
die es gegeben hat werden geprüft es ist
jetzt nicht so dass man jetzt gesagt wir
machen nichts und es gibt auch andere
als 50.000 gewesen wären wenn wir über
120 tausend russische soldaten sprechen
aber 5000 er aber auch da gibt es ja
dass wir natürlich jetzt nicht einfach
die die ukraine mit dingen die sie
nachdem sie gar nicht fragen bewerfen
und natürlich erst mal hören müssen was
was die denn sich wünschen aber es
bleibt dabei dass wir die balance
zwischen gesprächsfäden und
möglichkeiten auf der einen seite und
auch sehr klar und deutlich machen dass
eine weitere russische aggression und
das will ja nicht die erste die russen
sehen der seit acht jahren in der
ukraine auf der krim und im donbass mit
militärischen kräften dass wir das nicht
einfach jetzt werden laufen lassen und
das einhalten preis haben es ist die
zeit auch besondere formulierungen
annalena baerbock die außenministerin
sagt der härteste knüppel ist nicht
immer das intelligenteste schwert da
muss man jetzt auch ein bisschen drüber
nachdenken wir erinnern uns an den
berühmten slogan knüppel zu pflugscharen
hutter
dass wir sie sagen helfen sie uns ich
glaube dass sie nicht angetreten ist um
poetry slams zu gewinnen aber was sie
gerade gesagt haben bestärkt mich darin
dass wir es alle nicht machen sollten
ich glaube dass der zentral dass man
sieht wie unermüdlich gerade reist um zu
deeskalieren und das macht sie in
engster abstimmung mit dem kanzler der
sehr viel telefoniert um um zu
deeskalieren das oberste ziel ist jetzt
dass es in europa nichts von dem krieg
kommt und dass wir auch jetzt nicht
einfach der russischen seite wirklich
billige anlass gegeben um zu provozieren
es deute sehr vieles darauf an dass sie
darauf warten und da ist das spiel
sollte man nicht mitspielen norbert
röttgen ist bei uns cdu-außenpolitiker
herr röttgen sie sagen jetzt
interessanter weise ja die ukraine
braucht waffen aber sie braucht die
nicht von deutschland
genau die ukraine braucht waffen sie ist
bedroht inside 2014 sind um die 14.000
menschen getötet worden in der ost
ukraine
also es ist krieg und
russland hat mit über 130.000 soldaten
eine invasions fähige armee
zusammengestellt und die ukraine hat das
recht sich zu verteidigen
der selbstverteidigung oder die ukraine
ist keine bedrohung für russland
und darum ist es auch moralisch und
politisch legitim der ukraine in ihrem
recht sich zu verteidigen beizustehen
eine position deutschland hat sich omid
nouripour ihm gesagt hat seit jahren
entschieden das nicht zu tun aus meiner
sicht richtig
nicht aus gründen unserer vergangenheit
die verbrechen des zweiten weltkrieges
haben sich gegen ukrainer und russen
gerichtet daraus ist kein argument
abzuleiten auch nicht dass man nicht
einen bedrohten voll bei stehen darf als
leere unserer geschichte sondern es gibt
aus meiner sicht ein argument warum wir
es nicht tun sollten weiterhin
und zwar weil deutschland mit russland
gegenüber russland über besondere
gesprächsmöglichkeiten verfügt die haben
wir
gesprächsfähigkeit
gesprächsmöglichkeiten wenn wir waffen
lieferten würden wir diese
gesprächsmöglichkeit und
einflussmöglichkeit beschädigen oder
zerstören
das ist aus meiner sicht das politische
argument warum deutschland ist nicht tun
sollte nicht weil wir irgendwie besser
sind moralischer sind sondern weil es
ein anderes gut gibt der einflussnahme
auf russland das ist aus meiner sicht
dass rational die ratio dieser politik
so würde ich sie auch begründen aber
eben nicht das recht waffen zu liefern
irgendwie in frage stellen wenn man das
so sieht wie ich es hier dann heißt es
aber auch dass man diese
gesprächsmöglichkeit nicht als ausrede
benutzt nichts zu tun sondern dann muss
man sie auch nutzen und dann muss man
eben auch mehr tun meinen dass jetzt
auch nicht zu sagen mehr als floskeln
die stunde der diplomatie wir brauchen
politische lösen das ist ja klar der
punkt ist nur wir müssen uns darüber
klar werden was will eigentlich putin
und ich glaube er weiß was er will er
will ihr wissen es nicht und wir wissen
es nicht das ist genau der punkt wir
wissen uns nicht und wir wissen vor
allen dingen nicht sind wir eigentlich
bereit diese ordnung der freiheit der
selbstbestimmung der einigkeit die die
ordnung europas nach dem kalten krieg
ist auch zu verteidigen sind wir bereit
dafür etwas einzel das sind die
ungeklärten fragen europas und
mindestens die erste frage diese ordnung
zu verändern die es für putin geklärt
hab da beginnt für in die taktiken die
reden über den deutschen beitrag und wir
reden über den deutschen bundeskanzler
gleich nochmal ulrike franke sollen
begrüßt unbedingt begrüßt werden nicht
unbewusst unbedingt begrüßt werden und
zwar in london sie ist militärexperten
und politikwissenschaftlerin frau franke
sie müssen uns helfen sterben will im
westen also niemand für die freiheit der
ukraine die ukraine ist einfach kein
bündnisfall sie ist kein nato-mitglied
was wir jetzt machen ist zu sagen wir
geben ihnen waffen und jetzt verteidigt
euch mal schön ist dass die situation
zum gewissen teil ja es ist richtig dass
zum beispiel die usa gesagt haben sie
werden keine amerikanischen soldaten in
die ukraine schicken und erkämpfen
lassen weil es eben keine nato
mitgliedsland ist ich muss aber sagen
wenn ich mir jetzt die diskussion an
höre ich finde wir machen es uns in
deutschland ein bisschen einfach wenn
wir so tun als seien waffenlieferungen
an die ukraine eskalation ich würde
anders argumentieren sagen es gibt
eigentlich zwei gründe warum man waffen
an die ukraine liefern will das eine ist
ganz wichtig dass es den signalwirkung
man will zeigen dass man die ukraine
unterstützt und eben auch gegenüber den
anderen verbündeten am zeigen dass man
hinter der
position der der nato steht und das
andere ist ein abschreckungs logik und
das ist letztendlich eine deeskalation
slogan sie die idee von den
waffenlieferungen ist ja nicht zu sagen
wir rüsten die ukraine so auf dass sie
sich komplett gegen russland verteidigen
können das funktioniert ja vom vom
größenverhältnis nicht aber man sagt
eben man rüstet die ukraine auf so dass
man denen die kosten eines russischen
angriffs quasi nach oben treiben kann
und dadurch hofft man eine situation zu
schaffen dass russland es sich quasi
noch einmal anders überlegt und und
nicht angreift das ist die logik und das
ist keine eskalation slogan finde das
machen uns in deutschland sehr einfach
wenn wir immer so tun waffen und militär
das ist per se eskalation nur diplomatie
und reden es würden wie die die einzige
möglichkeit natürlich müssen wir reden
natürlich braucht es diplomatie das wird
ja auch gemacht aber mir erscheint das
ein bisschen zu eindimensional hier
möchte ich auch noch mal nachfragen frau
franke wenn sie sagen die ukraine hätte
niemals eine chance so viele waffen zu
besitzen das die russen darauf
tatsächlich reagieren würden und das
fürchten müssten also angst davor hätten
sondern sie diente nur dazu den preis
hochzutreiben
dann heißt das wir inkludieren bei
dieser abschreckungs logik natürlich das
sterben der ukraine das weitere sterben
die logik ist zu sagen man treibt den
preis eines möglichen angriffs hoch
wir gehen momentan ist es macht nicht so
wahnsinnig wir sind von dem szenario
auszugehen wo wir wo russland irgendwie
komplett in der ukraine einmarschiert
und das ganze land besetzt erscheint
eher unwahrscheinlich dafür reichen im
übrigen auch die selbst die 100 oder 120
tausend russischen truppen an der grenze
nicht insofern dass es dass es aktuell
weniger die überlegung sondern die idee
ist man rüstet die ukraine so auch nicht
dass sie sich gegen das komplette
russische militär verteidigen kann
sondern dass
putin und russland das sich quasi noch
mal überlegt ob es sinn macht ein
angriff zumal zu machen zb eben über den
über den don was wir begrüßen katharina
micenko sie ist verlegerin und autorin
und ist uns aus kiew heute abend
zugeschaltet tommy schenke sie
leben in kiew sie leben und überleben
jeden tag in kiew ist das was die
menschen in der ukraine jetzt am
dringendsten brauchen kriegsgerät aus
deutschland
ich glaube die menschen in der ukraine
brauchen eine sehr klare politische
position und waffenlieferung ist ja
nicht nur
waffenlieferung an sich es ist auch eine
die verweigerung dieser lieferung wäre
auch
als eine politische gäste
interpretierbar und in der kombination
mit dieser nord stream geschichte ließ
sich diese gäste als russland
freundlichkeit und keine bereitschaft
die ukraine in so einer schwierigen
denn sie deutsche und richtig zu
unterstützen
und ihn noch mal zu ihrem präsidenten
herrn sie lenski gefragt er macht
verschiedene äußerungen zur situation
seines landes haben sie das gefühl dass
er den partnern im westen tatsächlich
vermittelt das und was die ukraine nun
am dringendsten braucht
ja ich merke wir sind jetzt in einem
sehr intensiven
austausch so aktiv im außenpolitischen
sinne war die ukraine schon lange nicht
und ich glaube dass diese intensität von
gesprächen mit ganz verschiedenen
ländern und ihren vertretern sehr
produktiv genau für diese diplomatische
und politische lösung des konfliktes
sein könnte und deswegen glaube ich
ist er ja diese waffen geschichte und
deutsche position jetzt so
wichtig weil wir ja in diesem
diplomatischen prozess gerade sind und
wir werden auch darüber noch diskutieren
und begrüßen in moskau dr jaroslaw wie
er leitet das zentrum für deutschland
forschungen in
moskau wir haben herr bierhoff mit einer
karte mal versucht zu zeigen in welcher
situation
sich die ukraine befindet an der grenze
zu russland auch mühelos noch deutlich
gemacht und zu sehen es sind
mittlerweile
diese verbände auf russischem
territorium zu sehen in anderen staaten
europas ohnehin und auch die positionen
von nato streitkräften nur um auch zu
verstehen in welcher lage und in welcher
situation
europa da gerade ist warum sollen sich
die ukraine davon nicht bedroht fühlen
happy end
weil das schon ganz anders aussieht ist
es erstaunlich für der polizei westen
seit 2007 der fall die interessen von
russland versteht interessieren sich von
den einfluss bereichen
angeht sondern das interesse von
russland seine sicherheit zu haben auch
an der grenze an der nahe liegenden
gebieten keiner denkt im westen es
könnten dann auch die anderen ziele von
russland seien aufmarsch schon da haben
sich heute schon einmal gehört rund 1100
20.000 und 30.000 wer mehr also wer hat
das gezählt man bezieht dann auch auf
unterschiedlichen quellen ja die truppen
sind da aber das ziel ist anders das war
dann eine zwingende einladung von
amerikaner letztendlich die
verhandlungen anzufangen und das war das
ziel und das ist keine drohung
qualitäten sagen wenn russland das
gewollt hätte weder sie haben heute von
vielen konjunktiven gesprochen das hätte
das gemacht wofür denn wer hat dann auch
das interesse an einer seite keine
spricht er über es gibt dann eine
ukrainische konflikt kann es spielt
darüber da dort runde 1000 ukrainischen
truppen stationiert werden denen nur
35.000 von den kämpfern von nicht
anerkannten republiken gegenüberstehen
keine rutschen drucken in donetsk und
lugansk und diese truppen werden
bewaffnet mit italien und euro wie auch
immer man sagt letale waffe kann ein
offensiver waffe sein und daran ist muss
komisch interessiert dass plötzlich zu
einem seiner heißen phase konfrontiert
kommt wenn ich so ein drei punkt wir
haben noch von mir gab kommen nicht
gesprochen daran ist russland adressiert
das zu erfüllen und das nicht um gottes
willen was hier geschieht und russland
spricht von der zentralen integrität von
ukraine mit daniels und lugansk jemand
auch die entsprechenden punkte von musca
abkommen creme ist aufgegliedert
bestandteile von russland wie das auch
cream von damals 91 zuge kam eine
besondere geschichte soll entschuldigung
sie möchten und das war ihr argument als
sie anfingen aufzuzählen worum es den
russen geht sie sagen sie möchten dass
die amerikaner an den verhandlungstisch
kommen sie denken dass die amerikaner
dazu nicht bereit sind
sie waren nicht bereit und da sehen wir
das aber dann die ganze geschichte habe
2007 2000 da die angebote waren im
zurückgewiesen von den auch unteilbaren
sicherheit mit präsidenten mit wege seit
2004 10 russland wird 19 uhr großer
betrachtet also man hat alle dialoge
eingefroren und alles was auch moskau
angeboten hat was nochmal format dann
geht man hat immer dann zurückgewiesen
und jetzt letztendlich gelungen ja mit
solchen methoden können wir das
kritisieren aber trotzdem der westen ist
jetzt am verhandlungstisch
richtig und dennoch ist ja wenigstens
eine veränderung bemerkenswert herr
bierhoff das in den putin mittlerweile
und auch ganz offiziell den ukraine das
recht auf eine eigene nation und einen
eigenen staat ab spricht er spricht gar
nicht mehr von der ukraine sondern von
den kleine russin sie haben uns erzählt
das weiß man dass ihre frau ukrainerin
ist wie fühlt sie sich damit vom
russischen präsidenten jetzt nicht als
ukrainerin anerkannt zu sein sondern als
kleine russin
man hat dann bestimmte daten raus
genommen
putin versuchte von der geschichte von
der geschichte zu sprechen
sie bezweifelt nicht die ukraine alles
ein ist
eine selbstständige staat und
gibt ein ukrainisches volkes russische
volk weissrussischer belarussische
genannt wird und es gibt dann
tatsächlich unheimlich viele gemischten
familien die sowohl zur ukraine als auch
zu russland gehören wie auch meine
familie aber putin bezweifle dass nicht
er versuchte das auch eine historische
analyse zu machen oder zu ziehen also
vollziehen und da hat man dass die
zutaten sind raus genommen wie den augen
sein zitat von geopolitischen
katastrophe wo es da wirklich 25
millionen außerhalb von ihren grenzen
plötzlich
von heute auf morgen
gedacht waren und das fahrzeug das von
bitte nicht vergessen also dass sie
vieles was hier geschehen da sind auch
die zeitbombe 97 von nelson and co dann
angelegt worden sind und zur zeit
spricht putin nicht von sowjetunion er
spricht darüber dass postsowjetischen
raum die existierenden krisen zu
überwinden hat und deshalb sprechen
dürfen zunächst den südkaukasus von
mittelasien und so weiter also
davon ist die rede nicht von der
wiederherstellung von sowjetunion wir
kommen der frage was putin eigentlich
will ein bisschen näher und sind herr
röttgen bei ihnen man könnte jetzt erst
mal sagen eines hat putin sicherlich
geschafft nämlich quasi eine
wiederbelebung der nato
französische präsident könne nicht mehr
auf die idee die nato für hirntot zu
erklären sondern die reaktion der nato
ist ja da
war also wenn überhaupt dann jetzt warum
jetzt warum macht putin jetzt diese
provokation
also ich glaube putin dann kann jetzt
keinen zweifel mehr geben ist
entschlossen die ob frage ist geklärt er
ist mit dieser ordnung wie sie sich nach
dem ende des kalten krieges ergeben hat
nicht einverstanden russland an den rand
gedrängt wir sieht und um ihn herum gibt
es überall dass die sehnsucht der
menschen nach demokratischer
selbstbestimmung korrupte regierung
werden zum teufel gejagt ob das in bella
also in belarus muss da ist es nicht
gelungen der der diktator führt krieg
gegen das eigene volk in der ukraine ist
es gelungen
gelungen das ist eine bedrohung seiner
macht denn es ist wenn das gelingt und
erfolgreiche ist eine frage der zeit
dass die russen sagen warum sind wir
eigentlich die einzigen und die letzten
die keine selbstbestimmung haben und
keine modernisieren und er findet sich
nicht ab damit dass russland keine harry
um keine imperiale macht mehr in europa
ist das will er verändern das ist
unverrückbar und ich glaube das ist sein
lebensziel und dann ist die frage wann
und wie ich glaube auch dass das keiner
wirklich weiß vielleicht weiß putin es
selber noch nicht ich glaube dass er es
ist der es entscheidet aber keiner
sitzen seinem kopf es könnte sein dass
er die gelegenheit für günstig hält die
europäer sehen und sie haben diese
gelegenheit für günstig zu halten daran
sind in erster linie die deutschen
schuld nein es sind die europäer sich
die europäer sind
putin für putin sind die europäer hier
nimmt sie nicht nimmt uns nicht wirklich
ernst und wir benehmen uns auch alle so
dass das grund hat
wir sind in einer verfassung wir sind
eigentlich der schlechtesten verfassung
seit den römischen verträgen und einig
jeder macht seine eigene veranstaltung
jeder ist mit sich selber beschäftigt
das sind die europäer für die für die
die diese in den putins kalkulation da
um zu spalten dass man sie aufeinander
hetzt und gegeneinander aufwiegelt und
spaltet und die amerikaner die
amerikanische demokratie ist auch in
einer tiefen krise der sieht ja auch der
jetzige präsident tut sich natürlich
schwer die republikaner sind weiterhin
unter der knute von donald trump also
ist die große frage
halten die das eigentlich aus die frage
der resilienz der widerstandsfähigkeit
halten sie das aus wenn sie kosten
bezahlen müssen halten die das aus einem
höheren energiepreise halten die das
auswendig dem ein was anbietet dem
anderen nicht
darum könnte es sein dass sie das dazu
geführt dass das ist eine günstige
gelegenheit und ich glaube zweitens dass
er das gefühl hat dass die zeit gegen
ihn läuft er sitzt nicht da und sagte
ich habe alle zeit der welt er weiß auch
dass er älter wird er seine uhr auch
tickt und das hat glaube ich zu dieser
situation geführt wie das in ein oder
zwei wochen aussieht weiß ich nicht ich
glaube keiner weiß ist aber das hat zu
der situation geführt dass er jetzt kann
wenn er will wenn er ist taktisch für
opportun hält so ist meine analyse wir
sind noch mal verbunden mit london frau
franken der amerikanische präsident ist
schon angesprochen ein kleines
eindringen in die ukraine wäre nicht so
dramatisch der ist so breit ist dann
wurden hier in europa ist dieser
schwache amerikanische präsident der
vielleicht nur für eine amtszeit gewählt
sein kann und wird auch ein grund für
putin oder würden sie sagen die
situation in europa ist ausschlaggebend
ich denke eigentlich dass weder die
situation in den usa noch in europa
wirklich ausschlaggebend ist also diese
frage warum jetzt würde ich eigentlich
beantworten mit warum jetzt nicht ich
denke es ist sehr klar dass punkten wie
herr röttgen ja angesprochen hat die
europäische sicherheitsarchitektur
verändern will er will möglichst wenig
usa in europa möglichst wenig nato in
europa und vor allen dingen möglichst
wenig nato in seiner umgebung es geht um
einflusssphären das würde ich schon
sagen und natürlich die haben gerade
eine schwierige situation innerhalb der
nato es wurden schon einige elemente
aufgezählt wir haben auch
präsidentschaftswahlen in frankreich wir
haben eine relativ schwache regierung in
schweden also es gibt es gibt viele
aspekte
das ist alles auf der praktischen ebene
vielleicht spielt das mit eine rolle
aber meines erachtens sind das alles nur
so kleinere elemente und jetzt nicht der
grund warum das jetzt kommt der grund
ist wirklich ein viel fundamentaler und
in einer union von 30 starten wir jetzt
innerhalb der nato gibt es immer
irgendwelche die gerade politisch
vielleicht nicht so gut positioniert
sind aber das schreibt das nicht für
ausschlaggebend
mit der spiegel hat in dieser woche drei
frauen interviewt herr nouripour einmal
die tochter auch von chruschtschow und
focus schober sagt warum sollte putin 40
millionen ukraine
einverleiben wollen die ihn alle hassen
ist das ein argument was glauben sie was
wladimir putin will will er krieg will
er uns nur
nervös machen will uns
er verzweifelt machen will er und sagen
ich würde sehr gerne putin für stehe um
diese frage beantworten zu können aber
ich habe die letzten jahre gelernt
spätestens seit 2008 dass dieser frage
warum sollte er das tun nicht maßgeblich
ist 2008 gab es dann den einmarsch in
georgien
wir hatten den einmarsch in moldau in
die moldau hinein jetzt haben wir seit
2014 die situation in der ukraine
und deshalb ist am ende des tages dieses
erklären wollen ganz ganz zentral um
vorauszusehen aber nicht ausreichten wir
haben ja noch verstanden der gesagt hat
zentral ist für wladimir putin heute das
jahr 1991 und er möchte im grunde in
diese pre sowjetischer zeit zurück da
gibt es streiten sich nun die historiker
hat es damals gorbatschow gegenüber das
versprechen gegeben dass die nato sich
nicht ausweitet
und baker soll es gesagt haben aber
niemand hat es irgendwie schriftlich
festgehalten was auch immer warum hat
man es wenn es denn nicht geschehen ist
damals der sowjetunion nicht angeboten
dass die nato sich nicht richtung osten
bewegt ist ja eine berechtigte frage
klar aber dass in souveräne staaten herr
bierhoff hat gerade gesagt das ziel von
putin wäre ja dass die amerikaner wieder
verhandeln wenn ein land mit einem
zweiten land irgendwie problem hat warum
greift es dann ein drittes land an orten
stationiert 120000 euro an der grenze es
macht keinen sinn wir reden über
souveräne staaten die frage ob die
ukraine in die nato kommt wird in erster
linie nicht in moskau nicht in berlin
nicht in brüssel und auch nicht in
washington entschieden soll in kiew sie
müssen wissen ob sie wollen dann müssen
wir dann darüber nachdenken ob er sie
aufnehmen wollen aber das entscheide
nicht drittstaaten und das grund denken
dass diese staaten souverän seit belarus
auch das kleine land das gerade
wahrscheinlich am ersten und am mit am
leisesten unter die räder kommt nach
nachdem was wir gerade auch seit
eineinhalb jahren dort erleben dass es
dieses denken ist wir stehen zum
internationalen recht und zur
friedensordnung in europa und die
beinhaltet dass jedes land ein eigenes
recht hat zu entscheiden wo es hingehört
und nicht irgendwelche länder dann
übereinander mit dann entscheiden dieses
eine land kommt jetzt die meinen
vorgarten und das andere kommt in den
die
landmassen wie im 19 jahrhundert sind
keine staaten die anzuerkennen sind
sondern wie lavrov gesagt hat sind
verwaiste territorien also auch pohle
die baltischen verwaiste territorium
territorien nach dem kollaps der
sowjetunion und des warschauer paktes
so und wir sind herr schulz noch mal bei
der zentralen frage der konjunktive
deutschland hat besondere
gesprächskanäle deutschland hatte diese
besonderen gesprächskanäle ja auch unter
angela merkel
und hatte sie unter gerhard schröder und
will sie nun auch unter olaf scholz
haben was glauben sie denn mit diesen
besonderen kanälen wladimir putin
gegenüber seiner regierung gegenüber zu
erreichen wenn es solche pläne gibt das
russische reich zu vergrößern
internationale diplomatie beginn beginnt
und das hat er heute wunderbar
dargestellt mit der anerkennung der
realitäten wenn es so ist dass die
russische armee so überlegen ist und der
hat mal gesagt ich stehe in 24 stunden
kiew wenig will dann sind auch
waffenlieferungen an die ukrainische
armee symbolpolitik dass er eben gehört
nur in internationalen konflikten lösen
symbol politische entscheidungen nichts
deshalb glaube ich dass wir das sehr
ernst nehmen muss rusal aggressor das
ist eindeutig und die aggressive politik
russlands ist begründet durch das was
großmächte tut ihre interessensphären
außen bereiten das mal lieber einigen
staaten von amerika das macht china das
macht doch die russische föderation
wenn jetzt diese ausbreitung
interessen berechtigte interessen
anderer länder betrifft in diesem fall
die territoriale integrität der ukraine
die sicherheit der mittel und
osteuropäischen staaten der welt ich
gestraft dann ist der beste weg damit
die fest von überzeugt la die mir putin
an den verhandlungstisch zu bekommen
dann ist ihre frage völlig berechtigt
was kann man ihm den ladenmieten um ihm
etwas anzubieten muss man erst mal
verstehen war sehr mittel und deshalb
muss man mit ihm reden und insofern sind
die gesprächskanäle von größter
bedeutung ich glaube wir werden in einer
neuen sicherheits ordnung in europa wenn
wir die diskutieren sozusagen in einer
neuen konferenz für sicherheit und
zusammenarbeit in europa drei dinge tun
müssen europa muss sich mal darüber
einigen wer verhandelt jetzt eigentlich
das wäre meine nächste frage gewesen
also herr stoltenberg ist zu hören und
zu sehen frau von der leyen nicht wer
ist das aus europäischer sicht putin
will mit der europäischen union nichts
zu tun haben das kann ich ihnen sagen
dass ich einmal der präsident der
europäischen institutionen die nehmen
uns nicht ernst und osama sage das kann
ich verstehen wenn ich mir anschaue was
da in brüssel läuft diese
zerstrittenheit ist ja eine ermutigung
zu sagen die spalten wir weiter gestern
hat ein mann der putin intellektuell und
von seiner moral sehr artverwandt ist
herr orban mit ihm gerade ein separates
abkommen geschlossen der ist ja sowieso
dafür berühmt dass er die europäische
union von ihnen und spaltet damit ist er
der beste verbündete von putin ich
glaube dass wir folgendes tun müsst es
gibt die istanbuler vereinbarungen im
leben drin steht die sicherheit eines
landes darf nicht die sicherheit eines
anderen gefährden und es gibt das
budapester memorandum in dem die
territoriale integrität der staaten in
europa abgesichert ist über beides
werden wir mit der russischen regierung
reden müssen in welchem format auch
immer ich glaube dass die organisation
für sicherheit und zusammenarbeit in
europa osze eine gute plattform
darstellen könnte der europarat in dem
beide länder vertreten sind das
normandie format und heute hat der
bundesrat gestern hat der bundeskanzler
angekündigt dass er in die usa fliegt
und im anschluss nach kiew und moskau
fliegt das finde ich ist ein gutes
zeichen denn herrn der unita dem herr
nouripour hat eben folgendes noch mal in
erinnerung gerufen da selbst intensiv
daran beteiligen 2008 hatte der damalige
französische staatspräsident nicolas
sarkozy als präsident der europäischen
union deren damals war eine initiative
ergriffen ist der moskau geflogen und in
georgien haben sie die russen hinter die
grüne linie zurückgezogen also sie
angela merkel und nicolas sarkozy haben
eine gemeinsame initiative ergriffen das
minsker abkommen war ein resultat
deshalb glaube ich dass diese
kombination die russen nehmen die
institution nicht ernst aber die starken
mitgliedstaaten der eu insbesondere
deutschland und frankreich nehmen sie
sehr ernst und deshalb glaube ich dass
eine deutsch-französische initiative
marco riedl an bildschirmen mit dem
putin das finde ich schön aber wenn der
urlaub scholz direkt hinfliegt und
eruiert was willst du denn und worüber
sollen wir reden halte ich dass wir
einen sehr zielführenden vorgang ist das
problem nicht aber herr röttgen dass wir
georgiens zu den deutschen kanälen
was zu den deutschen kanälen sagen frau
franke was können die bewirken
die deutschen kanäle der kommunikation
das finde ich ein ganz interessanten
punkt einfach deswegen weil das ist was
das kommt so nicht im ausland und bei
den verbündeten also diese idee die wir
hier diskutieren dass deutschland in den
besonderen zugang zu russland hatten und
dass wir den nutzen sollten et cetera
empfinde ich natürlich alles gut und
richtig die verbündeten sehen nicht dass
wir das tun also ich spreche zu ihnen
aus london aber ich glaube noch
wichtiger ist die ist die sicht aus
washington und ich würde schon sagen
dass in den letzten jahr zwei wochen das
deutsche ansehen bei den verbündeten
extrem gelitten hat es gab diese titel
im wall street journal und anderweitig
ist deutschland noch ein paar
vertrauenswürdiger verbündeten ein also
zu sagen bleibt gibt es eine große
diskussion zu und meines erachtens kam
aus berlin leider in den letzten wochen
eine ziemliche kakophonie aus ja
aussagen die sich teilweise
widersprachen und wo auch viele optionen
direkt vom tisch genommen wurden also
wenn die glauben wir haben seinen
besonderen einfluss auf russland und
wollen den nutzen und haben eine klare
positionierung dann würde ich darum
bitten dass tatsächlich einfach besser
zu kommunizieren gerade eben den
verbündeten gegenüber weise kommt dass
hier nicht an und dann bin ich mir nicht
sicher ob das so in kiew oder in moskau
ankommt hier gibt es gesprächsbedarf
henry ford seine frau michelle der nazis
beschrieben wie gerade die stimmung in
kiew ist die stimmung ist eine mischung
von die deutschen helfen uns nicht und
die deutschen haben nord stehen und
machen darüber dreckige die es mit den
russen und deshalb lassen uns im stich
und
als einer der immer gegen nord stream
war und immer ein freund der ukraine
kann ich einfach nur sagen es hilft
nichts wenn wir uns die ganze zeit
gegenseitig erklären wie die wir nicht
helfen und wie wir schwachsinn es gibt
mehr riesige liste an auch im
sicherheitsbereich alleine riesige liste
an kooperationsfelder zwischen der
ukraine und deutschland und am ende des
tages kann man und das ist der einzige
widerspruch denn ich habe zu martin
schulz am ende des tages hilft natürlich
nicht wenn wir die ganze zeit erzählen
was in europa nicht funktioniert wir
haben für 214 gemeinschaftlich die
sanktionen wegen grimm und der bass
verhängt und immer verlängere das gab
immer lustige tänze auch in budapest um
dieser frage und am ende hat um dann
immer zugestimmt und deshalb sollten wir
vielleicht auch mal darüber reden dass
wir viele dinge miteinander hinbekommen
haben weil genau diese geschlossenheit
auch darzustellen wo sie funktioniert
ist hilfreich um es dann geschafft
allerdings den widerspruch nicht nur
eine bemerkung neben den vereinigten
staaten ist der zweitgrößte finanzier
der ukraine die bundesrepublik
relativ absolut wir sind den absoluten
wir sind
nicht mehr der größte sich mit
1,88
18 milliarden wir sind mit abstand der
verlässlichste umfangreichste größte
unterstützer in ganz unterschiedlichen
bereichen der ukraine heißt die deutsche
unterstützung darum ist es auch nicht
fair dass auf die waffenlieferungen so
zu konzentrieren aber frau franke hat an
einem punkt recht ich habe auch
überhaupt kein interesse hier mit
opposition und den
olaf scholz fährt fliegt am 8 februar
washington und dann eine woche später
kiew moskau wenn man das vier wochen
vorher gemacht hätte es stimmt wir sind
wir sind unsere zuverlässig das muss man
einfach zur kenntnis nehmen realität
unsere zuverlässigkeit wird in frage
gestellt das ist eine wirklich eine
situation die es nicht noch nicht
gegeben hat und wenn das stimmt mit dem
gespräch kann denn ich glaube es stimmt
wie weit was man jetzt bewegen die
zweite frage das habe ich ja eingangs
gesagt dann muss man sie auch nutzen
dann muss das auch sichtbar werden dass
deutschland sich reinhängt sich
engagiert reist kreative ideen
entwickeln wie kann man was in bewegung
moskau sie sind ein erfahrener
außenpolitik darf moskwa sagen so wie
ich
so wie ich das in so angespannten
situation die titelseite der zeit
vielleicht
erfolgversprechender bin ich aber sehr
gesprächskanal der nicht offen ist
vielleicht den erfolg bringt und deshalb
glaube ich ist das was zurzeit in der
bundesregierung gemacht wird sowohl von
frau bär burg also von herrn scholz sehr
zielführend wäre das ist gleich dran ich
muss herrn radio noch eine frage stellen
nämlich markus söder löst markus söder
ein problem der union aus meiner sicht
ist völlig klar zitat eine nato
osterweiterung um die ukraine steht auf
lange zeit nicht auf der tagesordnung er
würde fragen worüber streiten wir hier
eigentlich also ist es ein problem was
ist so schwer daran zu sagen dass die
ukraine nicht in die nato aufgenommen
werden kann in der nächsten zeit das
steht fest
dass das ist völlig unbestritten
dass man noch gar nicht zu dementieren
dass das anstehen könnte oder sonst was
das ist völlig klar das ist auf nicht
absehbare zeit muss man sicher sein ist
jetzt hier meine frage nach mausklick
und hier ist so herbert auf das immer
infrage gestellt wird
worüber ist dann herr putin besorgt die
ukraine wird nicht in die nato
aufgenommen
in absehbarer zeit also putin ist
besorgt dass solche diskussionen
nicht wie ein hollywood studio aussieht
wo die berater eingeladen werden die
tatsächlich die realität nicht kennen
aber daran denken was würde auch
tatsächlich in ihren köpfen vorkommen
und fest solche aussagen aggressor
coachen möchte dann zusätzliche
territorien meine damen und herren wir
sollten wir jetzt auch schluss damit
machen und tatsächlich das auch zu den
objektiven
realitäten übergehen was möchtet
botschaft schon gesagt dass wir
wenigstens
russland bei den anrainerstaaten
die situation hat war es nicht
es zu
situationen kommt wo in
ukraine oder warschau polen rumänien die
raketen stationiert werden oder wie auch
in estland wo dann auch in wenigen
minuten eine rakete 200 kilometer
direkte linie ist peter buck trifft man
sagt natur ist politische organisation
um gottes willen dieses auch militär
organisation 800 milliarden haushalt
wird der haushalt von
plus 200 milliarden von hier wo ich hin
dahinter ab 2014 zwei prozent
verteidigungsausgaben welche
verteidigungsausgaben das ist problem
und putschen sprich darüber lassen wir
jetzt über die infrastruktur von nato
sprechen die für russland inakzeptabel
ist inklusive ukraine und das ist
verständlich die sorgen das ist auch
dann nato kann auch dann aggressiv sein
und das problem das genauso wenn die
russen jetzt ein viel über nato gedreht
hätten und das kann ich auch nicht hören
das ist genauso jetzt können sie dann
aggression usw was auch herbert genehme
sagt aber das ist nicht der realität
und er sollte mit tatsächlich dazu
kommen dass auch herr scholz mit putin
und mit beiden darüber spricht weil sind
die tatsächlichen ziele von russland
dass viele nächte weil jetzt seit wochen
gesprochen wir sie haben herr bierhoff
aber sicherlich nicht vergessen dass es
eben auch im westen giftgas anschläge
gab attentäter attentate gab dass es
hacker angriffe gab dass die opposition
in russland
verfolgt wird
es für europäer stimmt aber
nicht mitkochen kkr angriffen von
einmischung so weiter können wir genau
sagen es wird dann auch ins russland
eingemischt er zählte also dass es
umgekehrt dass es auch die einmischung
in ihre angelegenheiten borussen sagt
wir haben die truppen stationiert aber
das ist unser recht uns ist klar dass
auch russland sollte dann erklären
weshalb das gemacht hat und das ist
weder dann ein anderes szenario ein
anderer film das wollte ich nur sagen
aber nicht immer sagen dass sich die
typen sind die tatsächlichen dinge die
auch geschehen hat das spricht man im
bett das hat geschehen und die leute
laufen und deshalb reden wir hier den
deutschen wird ja nun gerade unterstellt
dass sie ein sehr besonderes verhältnis
zu russland habe und dass sie eigentlich
zu dieser russischen regierung zugleich
mit putin viel zu freundlich sind olaf
scholz ist der bundeskanzler dieses
landes das hat er just gestern nochmal
gesagt aber er ist nicht der erste
bundeskanzler der spd und vielleicht ist
das
wandel durch annäherung
im kalten krieg war das willy brandts
ostpolitik
heute ringen die genossen mit ihrer
tradition
und einer neuen weltordnung
denn der wandel hat sich vollzogen
vor allem mit den nato osterweiterung
1999 und 2004 das westliche bündnis
rückt an die grenzen russlands vor
in deutschland regiert übrigens spd
kanzler gerhard schröder
es ist derselbe schröder der heute als
gazprom lobbyist die welt auf den kopf
stellt
und ich hoffe sehr dass man endlich auch
das säbelrasseln in der ukraine
wirklich ein stellt die neue spd führung
versucht sich klar zu distanzieren
die eskalation geht von russland aus wir
sind völlig klar dass alle optionen auf
dem tisch liegen
was scholz und klingbeil vermeiden
wollen allein das wort auszusprechen
dass die partei spaltet
die fertigstellung der ostsee pipeline
liegt auch im deutschen interesse
im übrigen bin ich davon überzeugt dass
es richtig ist weiter auf kritischen
dialog und wirtschaftlichen austausch
mit russland zu setzen aber das nord
stream zwei nicht in betrieb kommen kann
wenn russland einen krieg gegen die
ukraine führt das ist so
selbstverständlich dass es fast nicht
lohnt darüber zu reden
und dann sind wir bei den guten
geschäften herr schulz wladimir putin
mag sich über die loyalität von gerhard
schröder freuen ist ihnen ist ihnen
persönlich der ex-bundeskanzler
mittlerweile peinlich neu das ist eine
privatperson ja schröder und da spricht
nicht für die spd
das was er im rahmen seiner tätigkeit da
die russin unternehmen machte seine
sache gibt es verpflichtet die spd
überhaupt nichts und mich persönlich
auch ich habe im bundestags wahlkampf
erlebt das ehepaar aufsichtsratsvorsitz
von rosneft wurde während die ich
kanzlerkandidat war da habe ich mich
klar zu geäußert ich bin auch nicht
bereit das mitzumachen wenn ein
ehemaliger bundeskanzler
irgendwelche sachen sagt dann
anschließend sollten jetzt muss die spd
dazu stellung nehmen nein muss sie nicht
das ist die sache von gerhard schröder
meine position ist das nicht und ist
schon gar nicht die position von lars
klingbeil von lebe ich von dem ich den
eindruck habe daher ist es nämlich den
eindruck habe dass er sehr klar sehr
deutlich und sehr präzise die spd führt
er hat das gerade gesagt die eskalation
geht von russland aus wir müssen jetzt
alle wege gehen um diese eskalation
doch richtigen scholz noch herr klingen
weil da wird eben gesagt alles muss ja
muss ich die so willst du diese
eskalation stoppen dazu gehört alles auf
den tisch wenn alles auf den tisch
kommen dann müssen extreme zwei ja auch
genau so eben und da merkt man eine
gewisse vorsicht die ist subtil aber sie
erschließt sich auch ihnen herr
klingbeil und herr scholz würden sie
sagen herr schulz dass die spd immer
noch einen schröder problem hat einfach
weil sie mehr sind als nur seine
weggefährten
noch um 2 ist ein europäisches projekt
dessen zustandekommen habe ich noch
mitgewirkt sein europäisches projekt an
dem mehrere europäische staaten
beteiligt sind und es eine
privatwirtschaftliche angelegt das nicht
interessant ich war mit meinem sohn
nicht fertig eine privatwirtschaftliche
angelegenheit mit politischen bedeutung
grad der enorm geworden ist nur eine
sache möchte ich mal ganz klar sagen
wenn es zu einer heißen
auseinandersetzung käme zwischen
russland und der ukraine
dann ist noch stream zwei schüsse durch
die noch gar kein glas läuft überhaupt
kein problem mehr das problem wird dann
sein haben wir noch energiesicherheit
drehen wir sind empfänger von gasen
drehen wir uns das gas endgültig ab
und nicht mal das gas wird die
entscheidende rolle spielen russland hat
den größten finanziellen gewinn in den
letzten jahren die haben übrigens auch
eine volle kasse übrigens auch ein punkt
der putin motiviert aber die größten
gewinne haben sie nicht beim gas gemacht
sondern beim öl und der drittgrößte
exporteur von öl in die vereinigten
staaten von amerika ist die russische
föderation
wenn es wirklich zu einer konfrontation
dieser art käme dann ist noch stream 2
ein kleines element deshalb das ist eine
private angelegenheit ein großer
politischer aussagen aber die
reduzierung der ganzen krise innerhalb
unseres landes auch die nord stream zwei
ganz sicher ein grund wir reden darüber
ob wir
korrumpierbar sind n roll pur das ist ja
die unterstellung die im raum legt das
weil das ein projekt des ehemaligen
deutschen bundeskanzlers ist und weil es
europa und vor allen dingen deutschland
mit russischen es versorgt
wir damit natürlich in einer
abhängigkeit von russland sind die ganz
anders aussieht als für andere staaten
so ihre einschätzung ist gerhard
schröder sind die äußerungen von gerhard
schröder die einer privatperson was sagt
der chef der grünen und das ist ein
bundeskanzler ade und dementsprechend
spricht da immer in dieser funktion und
als
parteivorsitzender der grünen steht mir
eigentlich nicht zu für die spd zu
sprechen und ich halte die pipeline auch
nicht für privat projekt ich muss aber
sagen dass sehr olaf scholz auf seiner
reise in madrid auf seiner
pressekonferenz sehr klar und deutlich
nord stream auch von selbst genannt hat
als ein mögliches instrument was dann
beendet wird sollte es zum krieg kommen
und ein letztes noch die tatsache dass
wir hier sitzen und darüber räsonieren
ob im falle eines krieges die russische
seite dann einfach die die gashähne
zudreht zeigt ja auch dass wir wissen
dass die verlässlichkeit die wir seit 71
hatten seit 1971 in der sowjetzeit hatte
wir hatten kalten krieg wir hatten eine
konfrontation der blöcke aber gas ist
immer geschlossen dass diese sicherheit
nicht mehr da ist und dass wir wissen
dass im zweifelsfall russland nicht
verlässlich ist bei grad in das auch als
waffe benutzen würden wollen sie sagen
und dann ist jetzt trotzdem noch mal die
frage wer es olaf scholz eigentlich
beigebracht hat das ist nicht mehr eine
privatwirtschaftliche initiative ist das
war ja zunächst eine formulierung
sondern dass es jetzt tatsächlich ein
projekt ist das in diesem fall auch zu
unseren ungunsten aus schulen sorgt die
formierung von angela merkel bestimmt
danach frage ich gleich ein röttgen herr
schulz ist eine faire sache hier heute
im leben da haben sie ihn überzeugen
können wer hat ihn überzeugt dass es
eben nicht um eine privatwirtschaftliche
initiative geht sondern mehr ist ich
glaube das ist hier ernst doch nicht
darum geht ob durch scholz und berbalk
die sehr eng beieinander sind jetzt
einander überzeugt haben sondern wir
reden über einen drohenden krieg und in
dem augenblick ist es für alle personen
den amtseid geleistet haben und
eigentlich auch für alle die
verantwortung tragen egal welche partei
habe sie tragen zentral dass wir da
zusammen stehen und versuchen krieg zu
verhindern und da ist es klar wenn
gesagt wird ein preisschild falls und
zwar ein großes
großer preis den russland bezahlen
müsste für eine weitere aggression dann
heißt es dass wir natürlich auch nord
stream dabei haben da kommt glaube ich
urlaub schon selbst drauf vorher hatte
er gesagt er würde nicht dazugehören und
müsste nicht inkludiert werden wir sind
bei norbert röttgen hat es nicht auch
angela merkel wirklich auf ihrer liste
gehabt und über viele jahre
unbedingt auch dafür gekämpft dass nord
stream zu ende gebaut wird es waren
nicht ihre initiative sie hat auch die
amerikaner davon überzeugt dass die
nicht weiter protestieren gegen den bau
dieser mehr korrigieren sie mir nicht
sanktioniert nicht sanktionieren und zu
ende gebaut werden durfte das war